PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Welcome to "Get
Cooking in Cloud," where
we share the best recipes
to apply in your cloud kitchen.
I am Priyanka.
And in this episode,
we'll talk about a hot DR
pattern for applications that
are deployed on Google Cloud.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
We met Main Street Art
in the previous recipe.
But now, they've
gotten so popular
that they now have a
huge and global customer
base, which requires them
to be online all the time.
So they are setting up a
hot DR pattern with next
to no downtime.
Now, Main Street Art has
a unique advantage here.
Since they're deploying
their production application
on Google Cloud, they
can take full advantage
of the built-in HA features.
Here's how they
would set this up.
They would have to
create a VPC network
and then create a
custom image that's
configured with the
application service,
use that image to create
an instance template,
using this instance template
to configure a regionally
managed instance group.
This is to ensure resilience.
If the whole zone
was to go down,
the instance will still be
available in other regions
to keep the application running.
Make sure the HTTP and
instance health checks
are configured at the
managed instance groups
to verify that the services
and instances are properly
running within a group.
This ensures that if a
service or an instance fails,
the group automatically
recreates that instance.
Configure load balancing
using the managed instance
group that spans across zones.
Create Cloud SQL in
one zone as a master
and enable a replica
in another zone.
Doing this means that in case
the master becomes unavailable,
they can promote the replica
to become the master,
and then finally configure
the Cloud DNS to point
to the primary application.
As the application
has built-in HA,
if a part of the
architecture fails,
it basically heals itself.
And Main Street Art
team has to do nothing
to ensure their
application continues
to be available for
their customers.
If you would like to learn more
about building scalable web
apps on Google Cloud, check
out the previous episodes.
Well, there you have it.
If you are deploying an
application on Google Cloud
and have to meet those really
small RTO and RPO values,
then use some of the built-in
Google Cloud HA features.
That's all for today on
"Get Cooking in Cloud."
Here's hoping you're whipping
up your own DR strategy.
Join us next time, where
we will share the recipe
to implement DR for data.
If you would like to
see more such content,
don't forget to like and
subscribe to our channel.
[MUSIC PLAYING]